[Music]
hi everybody welcome to the data science
hangout if you're joining for the first
time today i'm rachel and it's great to
meet you
if this is your first hangout this is an
open space for the whole data science
community to connect and chat about data
science leadership questions you're
facing and what's going on in the world
of data science
the sessions are recorded and shared to
youtube as well as the rstudio data
science hangout site so you can always
go back and re-watch or find helpful
resources too
we also have a linkedin group that
tyler or hannah will share in just a
second here in the chat if you ever want
to continue
a certain discussion or meet people
from today as well
but together we're all dedicated to
creating this welcoming environment for
everybody
so we love when everybody can
participate in these and we can hear
from everyone
so there's three ways that you can ask
questions today
you could jump in by raising your hand
on zoom and i can call on you
you can put questions into the zoom chat
and feel free to just put a little star
next to your question if you wanted me
to read it instead
if it's maybe loud where you are or
something
but we also have a slido link where you
can ask questions anonymously as well
just like to reiterate we love to hear
from everybody no matter your level of
experience or area of work as well
and all these questions
asked today are up to you
i'm so excited to be joined by my
co-host for today yvonne carrillo
dominguez a data engineering manager at
bixel
yvonne i'd love to just start by having
you introduce yourself and maybe sharing
a little bit about
your work and the company that you work
out as well
sure thank you um
thank you for inviting me to to hang out
with you
i was feeling a little bit of impostor
syndrome because i was like i'm not a
data scientist i don't know what
what i can't contribute but i i hope
this
is helpful and it is helpful and
productive for you all
and well about my role i am the
engineering manager as rachel said and
my role
is similar to the
manager roles that you will see in small
companies because yeah we are a small
company and also the data team is still
small and we are
we are growing it um a little by little
but what that means for me is that i
i am leading a team
and also mentoring them
but i'm also still
in some contracts i will work as an
individual contributor as well so i am i
did an engineer in one of the contracts
while at the same time
um building a team of data
analysts engineers and scientists so
it's like all together so that's um
in a nutshell or in a high level what i
do here at excel
um well about pixel
we are a company that we do
uh consultancy
uh
work for
for the federal government so most of
our contracts are for for the government
um
there are opportunities as well for the
private sector and i think that's uh
where we are leading um
now but
yeah
the
kind of work that we do is
so digital services
for learning
for marketing communications um the
technology part that is the biggest part
while where we do
content
systems web applications
and then of course the data team
um yeah that's what we do
awesome thank you
and while we wait for questions to come
in from
the audience here i'm curious what's
something that you're most excited about
in the
data space in the next year or so
well um
one of the things that i am seeing and
mostly the federal government is what i
have more experience is that
uh
like some years ago most of the agencies
were
in
in the point where they had a lot of
data but they didn't know what to do
with it and or how to
um
ingest it in the cloud how to analyze it
like they just know that there were some
data
and now what i am seeing is that
a lot of agencies already have
um some sort of report system or a
dashboard or a data pipeline and they
are in another phase but they want to do
more things with that so they want to
start
like for real making decisions using the
data data treatment decisions
and
and using it also to
to lead or to
to use it for
to make uh policy changes so that's
something that i really
like and i'm really excited and
also i'm seeing more opportunities for
machine learning and predictions
something that i remember like even two
years ago most of the projects were
still
um in the point where they needed the
apartment so now it's like in the other
stage so i'm really excited about that
that's great thank you
i said i was going to start asking this
question after last week as well but i
i wanted to ask people so we can get to
know them a little bit better but what's
something that you like to do in your
free time outside of work
so
what i do
i i am
i'm not a super fun person but
well i have a dog and i like to
hang out with her and love her but one
of the things that i also like is to
cook and to bake
and i think that's something that i was
doing before the pandemic but
definitely like since the pandemic that
all that crew exponentially and another
thing about me is that i
i am a vegan so one of the things that i
like is to
veganize like dishes
and
for example in
i am from mexico so the mexican cuisine
is like very can be very vast but
many of the dishes have meat so try to
make them without meat is something that
i really like so that's something that i
do
yeah
nice thank you
that's that's funny because adam said
last week that cooking was his his side
uh or what he'd like to do out of work
as well
um i see tanya you asked a great
question in the chat do you want to jump
in and ask that live
yeah sure and i'll probably tag team
with libby's question too because it's
kind of all in the same vein
uh so you you mentioned that you are an
individual contributor and the data
engineer manager
manager and i'm just curious
how do you balance your time between
these two different roles i imagine it's
kind of
going from one mentality of doing to
thinking more high level so i'm curious
how you navigate that and then libby
asks a great question too of which do
you like better
um
that's interesting i think it depends on
the day um
but
yeah i think the thing that i enjoy the
most is to mentor people and to share my
knowledge
and
since i still need to like put my hands
on the code
and
and work with a team as an um
individual contributor i
i learned a lot there so that's
something that i
i try to
to take advantage of that like i mean in
a contract i
i will always meet people that know more
than me and whether they do things
differently as well
so that's something that i
like about that
um
that i can take and then
share that with with the rest of the
team i think at this point i'm starting
to enjoy more the manager role
uh rather than the
i say thing
right now
the two of them can have like stressful
times but the kind of problems that i
have when i am a mentor or a manager i
think i enjoy more like i'm more excited
about that
um well as an ic sometimes
the the work or the stress is about
setting up an environment and
i really enjoy that before right now i'm
like no i don't
i don't know if i want to spend my time
or most of my time and that i i still
like that
uh
[Music]
but
one of the things that i
get to do as a manager is also like the
designing solutions
or solutions are architecting
and that
with in that role i i need to
investigate new technologies new tech
stacks so i i need to set up that
environment but it is a new thing and i
am learning and i am figuring out if
that's the resolution or not
uh so that part i like uh while when it
is uh as an idea is
different i sometimes is kind of the the
if you're in a contract it's going to be
the same tech stack until the contract
ends
and
and as i say i still like that and i
i get benefit of that because i will
collaborate with people and i will learn
a lot so i still like that but if i need
to choose one i think i will work with
him on a year
i have a follow-up question
if that's okay
um so elon musk put out that thing that
was like
you have to be an engineer in order to
be an engineering manager
what do you think about that do you
think that having a technical background
is really important to your ability to
lead these engineers and mentor people
or do you think that you would still be
good at it if you didn't have a
technical background
i think you will still be good at it um
it helps me
because i can
understand some of the problems and i
can also help or to be the bridge
between
the data analysts and the infrastructure
engineers for example or other software
engineers
uh i i have that background and it helps
but
[Music]
i think the most important
thing is
to be empathetic with people and have
like listening skills there are other
things when you are
doing people management
that are maybe more important and i know
there are
especially in the i.t field that are
engineers that
want the engineer manager to know more
than them
but that's not always gonna be possible
uh
i have like some background doing uh
almost my career was in in as a software
engineer
but now that i am going towards uh being
a manager uh
like um
organically i won't be able to be in
contract so i won't have that deep down
knowledge
so
it's
i think it's not we shouldn't giving
a lot of weight to that
and
if you don't know something that's okay
and you can lead that person to the
person that will know or that will
mentor that person in that specific
specific skill
or get some
formal educational training for those
for them
and so there are other ways that you can
solve that or navigate that
um
if your role as an engineer manager
has the
solution architecting part that's like
different because well maybe
for that yeah you need that
background
but otherwise
uh no so there are different types or
managers so it can be very technical or
not in my case it is more technical
but
um
i think
what makes a great management manager is
that they have these uh people
management skills for sure
awesome yeah zoom has never done this to
me but for some reason i can see
everybody's faces but the rest of the
zoom controls have left somewhere
it just updated today right when i
joined so i think it's something with
that but we're good i can unmute so
i know that um
we had talked a little bit earlier
yvonne about
um
benefits of being
a data professional when talking to
senior leadership and i was curious if
you could
give us a little more information about
what you mean by that
yeah so
i i've seen that uh
senior leadership so that c-level and vp
like to talk with data professionals
because they
they feel like we are
or more flexible or more
we can give the information
faster
but
i think what happens is that when we
want to explain something
we
we're very good at
[Music]
using visual information as opposed to
use talking
so if i want to present a solution
and
i know what they want to hear they want
to hear
time resources money and i can't put
that in a nice chart because that's what
we do all the time and so they can see
it right away all the information that
they they need
and
so i think that's one of the benefits of
being a data professional at that if you
need to
um
share some information or some form or
to
lead some people lead some people to
some decision that you can do that with
with a dashboard or a chart and and it's
not like with that
you don't need to talk like obviously
you will need to explain things but even
then whenever they ask questions the
information is there so you can just um
like point to that uh like okay this is
the money that you are going to say for
this at the time that you that uh we we
call
uh save as well
so
yeah that's um something that i'm seeing
and it's not that
that i do that i see that with other uh
people in my team as well that whenever
they want to talk with other teams
they always prepare a dashboard or a
like very quickly like just like a
workflow for example uh when we talk
with infrastructure engineers as well we
have like the workflow maybe um
we won't know exactly the services that
we want but we can say i need some
storage here i need to run some r or
python script here and i need to order
storage here and i need some sort of a
database here and they can know or
suggest and we can work easier with them
so that kind of collaboration is always
easier when you have those visuals and i
think that's something that um
we do it um
very fast or
since this is what we do like to share
information with visuals like that's
something that
we leverage that when also contributing
uh or collaborating with other teams
that's a great tip to think about for
people who are in other functions of the
business as well
i see there was a question on slido a
bit earlier that was
when you get to your desk in the morning
and start your work day what's the first
thing you think about
well the meetings the meetings that i
woke up that day yeah and
sometimes i i have like very nice days
when i i just have like one meeting and
that's all
but yeah that's what i do to plan my day
and
so the hours that i i don't have any
meetings sometimes i block that time
like this is like my focus time uh and i
need to work
and
also like in so that's one of the things
that i did
planning my day like
meetings versus focus time but also if i
i have like a pending thing with one of
my team members like i know that they
are working on something maybe somebody
asked them an estimation or
um
like they need to do something and i
know that it's like time sensitive i i i
plan some time also just to
just to check in and see if they need
some support
um
and if not yeah all the day is going to
be just just focus time
thank you
i see justin you you had asked that
question or it sounds like someone was
about to jump in
you want to jump in with that question
justin
yeah sure hi everyone um rachel thanks
for putting these together these are
great this is my first time joining um
so really thank you for joining
i'm in the city of baltimore and um
my question is basically around like uh
you know a lot of a lot of folks who get
into data science are like really eager
to use kind of
new tools machine learning
um
but
like
and i i expect this to happen in
industry too but particularly in
government there's only we get kind of
constrained about like what we can
actually use it has to be either
sanctioned by i.t
um or at least needs to meet certain
guidelines and parameters and not
everyone knows how to use those tools so
how do you manage kind of those
expectations for folks
um about you know yeah that looks like a
great tool but like these three things
over here are the ones that our company
uses or that the government uses to
to to get our work done do you run into
those kind of frustrations or um
yeah yeah how do you
sometimes
yeah so there are like different reasons
why
that will happen so
the the first one is just budget
so if they already have a license um
let's say that they have a table license
but we see that we could
do it with power bi because they use
sharepoint for example um
but then it's like they don't have that
license and it's just budget and to
to get approval for tools and
and yeah money can can take time
so that's something that we need to
adapt like that's the tool that they
have and
if we see that
we can get the approval within time we
will take the risk
um otherwise we just go with the tools
that they have approved
and
and yeah just work around that and
another part is
what you were mentioning that they
already have some tools that they know
and they are used to that and it's hard
to
make them
make them the the move um maybe some
people really want to change but they
know that some users will have some
resistance to
to do that change and
that not not everybody is on on the
technology
uh
side or no they are not very tech savvy
so uh
we need to understand that part as well
that they have a job that is not related
with technology so it's it's going to be
hard to move
a whole group of people to to go to
another tool
so it depends on
on the audience as well
or how big of the audience it is because
one of the things that we do as well is
precisely learning services
so we can prepare
or we can propose that to prepare some
trainings
some documentation that they can use
so
we can use another tool but um the
reason is going to be or it should be
always because it is cost effective so
we are going to do it faster or is going
to be um easier to maintain
sometimes they are proposing things that
will require a whole team on their side
just to maintain that infrastructure or
software
um
and we can propose something that is
going to be just easier to maintain and
so at the end of the day is more cost
effective
so that's one thing um and most people
will like that so if if it is going to
save them time and money they are always
going to like that but then is there all
that part that they need some
training or education so that's
something that
we can also mitigate by providing those
services as well
and yeah and there are people that is
just afraid to change because they feel
that it's going to take more time to
change all this
and that is at the end of the day that's
money and maybe they don't have that
but if
if we
really do the the diligence to do that
discovery and say okay no at the
beginning yes it's going to take more
time but
then you are going to save all this um
so
that's something that we could do and
sometimes it's
just a no from their side maybe
they don't they didn't get approval
and
in that case we just need to tell them
what is going to happen like okay we are
going to use your tools and your
methodologies
but we are not going to be able to
to deliver all the things that you want
so with those restrictions this is what
we can deliver
and
and explaining
explaining them why like we cannot just
work with that or we cannot um
optimize or modernize your system if you
if we have those limits we can just do
like these three things for example
and um
most clients will understand that
because they know that it's
there's not much they can do as well
it's a really helpful
phrase too with those restrictions this
is what
we can deliver it
it looks like in the chat there are a
lot of people that are experiencing this
as well and are saying they feel your
pain justin so um
i'd love to stay on this topic
for a little bit longer if other people
have gone through this and have other
things to share as well
not to call on anyone i know
david you mentioned that you've had to
do this and and evan
yeah sorry rachel i was
trying to multitask here while you're
asking that question but yeah definitely
for those who don't know i work at nasa
and we've been trying to implement a lot
of different tools and
it's been a long arduous journey over
the last three or four years just trying
to get an infrastructure set up so it's
it's definitely definitely not an easy
task within the government at times and
i'm assuring industries the same way
but there's always a group that wants to
use no code low code type tools
and just buy a vendor
which for some of the organizations in
our in our agencies that have the
funding maybe that's easy to do because
they can
spend that kind of money on a tool such
as alterex which you know cost us five
thousand dollars a user per year
but my organization with little little
funds we need to be able to do things
with with uh coding uh so it's
definitely just a matter of keeping the
conversation going and showing the value
of open source technologies and other
resources rather than some of these no
kudlow could tap to us so it's not easy
but it can be done
sorry
thanks dude
yeah i see there's a lot of great
conversation happening in the chat
around that as well so if anybody else
wants to way and always
feel free to raise your hand here on
zoom too
i see uh jamie you have your hand raised
you want to jump in
sure um yeah just a brief note that two
also coming from a public uh
setting i'm in toronto uh with a
hospital group
um
we've recently been exploring some more
container-based tech stacks largely for
this reason to give
sort of the
the flexibility that some of our
engineers and scientists may want um
although at other other expenses too
like
if everyone's using their own language
and known frameworks can become
unmaintainable as well
um
uh other quick note um i've been kind of
surprised my own hiring how much
uh tech stack and a job description can
influence
um
what kind of candidates um you receive
too i'm just trying really hard to
hire a developer at one point and
just changing the
tech stack to something that was more
um
appealing to industry at the time um
completely changed how uh
how uh
what kind of candidates we had coming in
that's a very good point like hiring i.t
people is hard
and when you are in a public sector
jesus come there
right here
i see there are a few other questions
coming through on slido as well and
he found one was what are some of the
hardest problems you find yourself
trying to solve over and over again
where it feels like
we don't have any good solutions
available yet
oh that's an interesting question
um
i don't know something that
i've seen
but or did i i've seen a lot it it's a
lot of
agencies needed that data pipeline
and
so they can consolidate all the
information in one place
and well i
i know that a lot of agencies have like
move on to the next stage that that's
something that was very repetitive like
um
and i think the challenge was exactly
what we were talking about like how you
can make a
this data pipeline
with those limitations so for example
um sometimes
the client doesn't want to go to the
cloud so you need to do it but they
wanted somehow
to be
optimized and maybe not automated but
the process
needs to be
optimized and some of the parts
automated so that's
that was very challenging and
and it's not um
an isolated
case like that
that happens a lot
um
and but
at the end of the day there was
there is a solution for that uh just we
can just work around that
i i don't know about a challenging
problem that
we
i mean like find out a solution
i mean as
as an ip as a whole um yeah i don't know
i don't know i will think about that and
if i think i'm in a better answer i will
definitely
go back to that
thank you very much
um i see sam you asked a question in the
chat i think it has a star there so i'll
i'll read it but it's have you worked on
projects where you inherited technical
debt and how how have you tackled that
to obtain a more future-proof solution
yeah
um
i i um
sometimes there are projects that are
just to go too good to pass on but it is
like somebody
started it so you are inheriting it and
then when you see the code you are going
to see a lot of to-do's in there and
it's like okay
good
it
it
it makes sense uh
also we have done um
work that needs to be done from scratch
and given the circumstances like there's
some unknowns
so it's i understand that part
um
but yeah i think the challenge sometimes
is to know why they
why they took some decisions on why they
are doing this tool why they are um
those students sometimes they don't make
sense with the final infrastructure or
or the whole solution
and
yeah i guess it's just
tackle one by one um because there's
always going to be that technical that
i think in one of the contracts that i
remember that was very successful at
that is that
we had some overlap with the
previous constructor
so they were able to tell those exactly
what that
they did was there like these are the
things that we didn't uh have time to do
or that
because of priorities we never got to
this
and then we were able to
have all those like in tickets and then
prioritize that like before
from what we heard of what they shared
this is what we need to work like right
now
um
before we jump into the actual work and
the rest is going to be just a little by
little
and some of those
tickets or things are not going to apply
anymore sometimes because maybe we
changed to another technology that we
found it was more cost-effective
sometimes we are inheriting projects
that are
maybe not super old but yeah like maybe
10 years and 10 years
ago like they they know it was very
different so yeah this will be obviously
more
uh or better tools that we can just
change
um
so yeah that some of the tech that is
not going to be
uh is not going to apply anymore
but i think
if we have that opportunity to ask the
previous constructor
we will have that and then prioritize if
not then
when at the beginning when we try to
to host that or to replicate the
infrastructure is is when we are going
to see like the biggest
things that we need to tackle
and
the the hidden ones are those like
to-do's in the code because you don't
see it right away but one thing that you
could do is just just try to find them
just look all the to-do's in the code
and and see
if you can um
identify one of those that are really
big or important um you're not going to
in some cases maybe most of them agree
or you're not going to be able to tackle
all of them sometimes this is like
really huge
but
yeah i guess yeah just prioritize and
focus on the big one
thank you
i i'd love to hear a little bit more
about your journey as well and you're
like jumping from a generalist software
engineer to specialized data engineer
and and what that was like
yeah so
well
so i graduated as a
computer systems engineer and at the
beginning i i didn't know what to do i
didn't know what the industry was
offering
um to begin with so i was just like
saying yes to any offer like whatever
life was showing me and
so i
had the opportunity to have very
different jobs so at the beginning i was
a front-end developer so i was migrating
an
application that
i will sound very old but yeah that's
that wasn't a standalone application in
a mainframe so with
green screens and that i was migrating
that to the web
and so i learned some web development
that
later on didn't help me a lot because uh
i was using technology that is not used
anymore but i was using java and
java really helped me out later
from that i jumped to be a tester so i
was doing software validation for
aircraft
engine so
a whole
new thing and then i jump into the
retail sector
doing back-end
for an operating system so there i was
using java as well and some crc plus
plus so it was more like low-level
programming
and
that
helped me a lot with my programming
skills
because that's where since it was a very
low level and it was like programming
like the signals that the keyboard
sends to the operating system things
like that
you need to use a lot of like link lists
arrays vectors all those data structures
that i was like i'm not going to use
these when i work well i
i was using all of those and i i
that helped me with
my coding skills
then i
that's all of that was in
mexico oh and and i also was a data
engineer in mexico that was my my last
job and then i moved in to
to the united states and i
at that point i knew i wanted to work
with data because i really like that it
wasn't like
as low level as operating system
and
but still i i got to to use those uh
coding skills uh to be parsing data so i
really like that
but when i was here i
i knew that i needed to
to get any opportunity that i have um
and i was
i learned some
uh
web
application web development frameworks
like
ruby on rails and php and django and php
with drupal and
go like different stacks there and so i
felt that i was like moving around i
also was in the infrastructure team for
a while
so i was learning like a lot and
that
that
that was helping me
to to get or to be
um
like put into
contracts because i
i was able to do a lot of stuff maybe
i wasn't very knowledgeable like in
anything but i knew a lot um i mean it
was very wide not not deep um
but i really
wanted to go to so one go back to data
and to
start specializing in something uh
i
i felt like okay i enjoyed all that like
learning
uh all those skills but i
i was seeing other people that they
really know a lot of what they know
so i want to be like that
um
so whenever i was able to be in data
contracts because i wanted to
to keep working for the federal
government
so to do that you need some clearances
especially when you are seeing data and
to do that i needed to be a youth
resident so finally i became one and i
was able to move to the data field again
and that's when i started specializing
more
and
yeah i really i really like that because
there's just too much to learn in all
the all these fields like infrastructure
front and back end
and
and it's
it can get crazy sometimes and just in
data there's a lot to learn as well but
at least i'm like more focused now on
what i want to do or where i want to to
go that's great thank you
and i agree with libby love to hear the
the generalist first specialist
conversation
i see victor you had asked a question in
the chat do you want to jump in
and i can
i can read the question to it
um it was what should be the road map to
data science
based on your experience and victor i'm
curious if
what perspective that's coming from like
just starting to learn data science or
which role you're in now
i think he's mute
yeah i think it's um yeah i
i
that i don't know if i really can't
answer that um
what i will
tell
any person that wants to go to data
science is well first find a mentor that
can really help you or guide you in that
part
um
but as a data engineer
i will encourage you to use
cloud tools to learn that part um
i know that the engineering may not be
the
the career path that you want to go
but
you will always need some data
engineering skills especially
if
you want to show something or to
prototype something
and you can be able to do that yourself
um
like just small projects um
you don't have to to start with big data
but obviously if the the scope of the
project is huge you will need a lot of
teams you need your data engineers
infrastructure engineers but just to
know what uh all the things
do i think that's going to be very
helpful
when you want to collaborate with others
um
so it will help you to collaborate and
also
to to you do your research or analysis
yourself like easier because you won't
depend on anyone so you can start using
some tools um
like for example if you want to use aws
you're going to start using s3 for
storage and maybe start playing around
with with athena or with blue for for
transforming the data
and and then when you
want that
so you want to to show
a proof of concept
maybe someone can take that and
and scale that um
and yeah i think
as a data scientist you still need to
clean your data anyway so i think that's
that's the part that i can't
talk about
um i know that there are other skills
like uh
um
statistics or
other or data analysis but i that's not
my area of expertise i just um really
encourage you
to
to grow also in your data engineering
skills that will make you a more solid
data scientist
maybe at the beginning
you need to focus on on other skills but
in if you want to jump into the industry
you will always need to do
something engineering in in a small
scale but yeah
that's really helpful thank you
i know mandeep you had asked a question
a little bit earlier in the chat do you
want to jump in and ask that
yeah
for sure uh hi everybody um so yeah my
questions around the languages you you
talked a lot about a
a variety of languages that you've
worked with um and you know languages
are similar and dissimilar in different
ways uh do you have a framework when
jumping between
the different languages um
and if so like or what is the first
thing that you look at when you're
looking at a new language that you got
to use or a new framework within aws for
example like what are you looking for
yeah that's a really good question uh
so
with i need to learn a new language
the
first thing that i
want to see is the the data types
they can change slightly between
languages but that's the first thing
that you all you need to to work with
with variables so if you have a text
it's going to be a string or it's going
to be other name um if you have a
boolean it's going to be just bool or
boolean or just to know the data types
and and then the
how they are called the the flow
um
the syntax is to do those flows like uh
the if for while
and
or switch case or other um
oh
it's just like i forgot the name of what
and what those are called but yeah how
to do those uh flows and
because yeah as well they change between
languages and they have like slide
changes sometimes is uh
four and then the name
of your temporary variable and then
colon and the list and sometimes it's
between parentheses and you need to do
it all the way around and just knowing
that can let you start with that so at
the beginning
my code is like super basic it will have
um
a lot of like if and force and maybe
that that's all but a little by little i
started learning more
of the ways
of optimizing the code but i think
that's the very very first thing that i
do or or try to learn and
one of the things that you also need to
do especially in data is just open open
a file open a csv open an excel file
open a json file so that's something
that i will do next so how are you going
to
read a json file
and so i try to learn that so what is
the the code that i will use if it is
python
uh
for example you will do it with pandas
they're just like a very easy
easy function to do that and and that's
um
that's and brings me to another thing uh
sometimes the language is not
specialized to handle data for example
python with r like it does specifically
for
for doing statistics and data so it's
very
it's
very easy to use for that
but python
uh
is not wasn't created for data
so
uh that's another thing that you will
need to do like what are the libraries
that are used for data analysis so okay
it is python and then you will see okay
there's numpy there's
pandas and and then try to see uh the
documentation and what are the things
that you can do with the data so that
that will be
um
maybe the last thing i will do and and
then it's just practice
just practice and trying to
to get
better at it
thank you
i uh i see there are a few slido
questions that touch upon a similar
idea and one was asking
about what your tech stack looks like
and then the other is around preferences
for data visualization and why
sure so for tech stack i
it depends on the contract i am working
on so yeah i don't have like um
one specific one
in in bixa we try to push to use aws
and we have these um
the infrastructure
we did like um
an environment that we can reproduce
because we are using terraform
so that's why we like that so if we know
that we are going to need some extra
pockets um maybe
a way to transform the data with
it with glue or lambda and then another
storage
we we can
deploy that infrastructure very quickly
because we
we have that already in terraform so
that's what we try to
to use and also
it has all the
requirements that some federal contracts
require that are
like the security compliances like
pedram for example
so
if
we are free to use any tech stack we are
going to use aws for sure and for
doing the etl or the extract transform
load process
we tend to use python
um
just because it's easier to deploy that
to [ __ ] and
it's always easier
to find people that know python uh
at some point we were
meaning more into art but it was
hard to find people it was harder to to
especially like two years ago it was
harder to use it in the cloud right now
it is it is getting better
um
and for the database solidization
tools um
well i like shiny i i work with uh
shiny on
on our studio and it's just very fun
this is very fun to work with
and i'm trying to make your your charts
and visualizations like preview and
interactive i i really enjoyed working
with that one
um
so i recommend that one just because
it's fun because i really like it and
and you can customize it as much as you
need sometimes when you're using a tool
like power bi or tableau
and and then the customer is like oh i
want to have my branding and my teaming
sometimes it's not as easy to
to to
customize it as much as a client want um
but it also depends on on the time or
the resources that that you have if you
have limited time but sometimes tableau
it's is the easiest
uh way to go and also is the one that
the the client knows the most
so if we can do it our way
maybe we are going to to go oh and we we
have like unlimited time yeah we will
need to decide between doing it with
shiny or maybe a react application it
also depends on who is going to do it
um
so but
my favorite one it will be shiny and
tableau
thank you very much
um
one other follow-up question i think um
someone had asked around
sharing apis
with inside and outside of the
organization is there a certain tool
that you use for that
i'm not sure i understand the question
like sharing
i think let me just double check aj i
see you asked that do you want to jump
in
yeah so a lot of times you know you have
great tables logic built into tables
your suppliers or people live within
cross-functionally you want to get to
hands on that data
but there are huge files right there
tables that get refreshed every so often
so
is there a way you prefer sharing those
those big data files internally or
externally like through api tools i
don't know if aws has those
technology
yeah
so yeah um
in projects we where
it's just easy to
push that data to github or gitlab but
that's not really a best practice maybe
that's something you could do when you
are in the prototyping
uh
like phase especially if it is like
private private data that you cannot
share that you shouldn't
um share that no like never in github
but
so we we have used two options there
so
just upload the data into s3 and give
access to the people that needs to to
have access and
with s3 that's a good tool because it is
reliable and it's scalable so you can
just
upload as much data as you want
and
you can also restrict the data
depending on
on what people can see so you can assign
roles to to the people and they will
only see what they need to see
so that's a good solution
and another one that we have used and
and this is if people that are not very
technical are are going to be
participating we use sharepoint because
we use a lot of microsoft tools so we
have teams and outlook so
it a lot of people is already familiar i
mean within pixel is already familiar
with sharepoint so that's the tool that
we are going to use
and you can also restrict the data
i think um
we will prefer s3 but depending on the
people that we are going to be
collaborating with maybe we are going to
be using
sharepoint and then when you are setting
up your environment
we know where to go to to download the
data and
if it is s3 you can just call it from
your code you can um if you have access
uh you just need that your aws keys and
you can just
uh i programmatically don't know that
data if it is sharepoint i think there's
way to do it
uh we haven't used those so but uh
that's
that's something to to explore
and
also we we use a lot of
um in another web applications we use
drupal which is a php framework for
content management
and if we need to download data from
there or to use content that is in there
if the
web application it is within the company
so the so pixel developers are
maintaining it we can ask them to
to create an api for us so drupal has
the ability to to use enable the api and
then we we can use it or we can request
them exactly what data we need and they
will
implement that endpoint for us and then
we just use it so i think that's
those are the three options that we use
where
when we need to share information
internally
i hope that thank you oh yeah that was
great thank you
and uh jorge i see i asked a question in
the zoom chat
around
data engineering positions do you want
to jump in and ask that
yes oh yeah yeah that's fine sorry uh
so the the question is uh regarding that
just uh just when i was transitioning
from developer to working in machine
learning uh i
i you know came across a lot of
positions that were uh in data
engineering uh and often times when i
had the conversation with the sorry i
think my cameras a lot
oftentimes when the uh
when i uh
had a conversation with a recruiter as
soon as they heard that i didn't have
experience in like spark or any of the
other distributed computing systems
mapreduce all of those i already only
covered it in grad school i didn't i
think
i didn't use it and like any job so they
just immediately lost uh interest and
they said no we just need uh interest
you know we did we need people with
experience in those and that was it
right so so you find uh
experiencing those frameworks necessary
to be a data engineer
engineer
um so you will learn that but to
when i am hiring people
i
and for a data engineer position i focus
more on the programming skills if you
are a good engineer you will learn
spark or map reduce in in no time like
zero is not
i i couldn't
want to lose a good engineer
because one skill
um
yeah no i don't i mean
it is necessary in terms of you will end
up using them but
to
in in
my opinion i i couldn't uh say no to a
person uh that i know it's good and i
can
teach them or mentor them in in these um
frameworks
when
i started
like my first job as a data engineer
i didn't know
any of those i didn't know uh what big
data was i
or mapreduce or spark i had a lot of
experience with java
that's why they hired me because uh
they they were like okay
she knows yeah but she knows how to
program that's more important and i i
think i agree with that i
and that's
the philosophy that i still
um
follow on after this moment and
so yeah programming skill that's basic
that you really need to do
to know how to use code
and if it is
one programming language that it is
more common in data like java or scala
python or r is going to be better
if
your programming language is more like
php or ruby those are good i would
really encourage you to to learn python
though
[Music]
but yeah
i i don't
i don't feel
those um
like spark or my produce are really
important or necessary when you are
looking for a job although if you are
having that experience uh
maybe you can do like a personal project
and try to use for example if you know
do you know python
yeah no i mean i'm not i'm not in that
position anymore right but it was when i
was transitioning uh i often found it
and i wasn't specifically looking for
data engineering jobs i was looking for
for machine learning engineer jobs and
uh and you know sometimes recruiters
contacted me for data engineering jobs
and i thought that maybe that was a good
transition right like if i wanted to
transfer uh to transition and uh uh yeah
it never like he never panned out
because of that because of that lack of
experience in i think so i just moved so
i i jumped i was able to jump uh
positions and went straight to working
in machine learning
so they it turns out better than yeah
but yeah but the idea that it's actually
good like uh being a data engineer and
then jump to machine learning i think
that makes sense um but yeah if anyone
is in like in that position
um
first i will try to show up my
programming skills and if you have the
time like maybe do a personal project
where you can use for example if if you
know python then use
pi spark just play around with it so you
can show that
you know how to use it you know um
i think what they are looking for that
you have experienced with concurrency or
parallel jobs uh
like the what you are saying here i
distributed computer frameworks uh
sometimes you you need to think a bit
differently
but if you start like playing around and
reading about that uh like that will
give you a better opportunity to to land
that job
i love um britney's comment in the chat
britney didn't mean to put you on the
spot but if you want to share that
sure yeah so sometimes what i found
being both on the candidate side and on
the interviewer side
is that especially when you're working
through a third party like a hiring
recruiter um they
may not know
all of the things like they're given the
job description and they may not know
that
hey i really need someone who has this
skill but if they don't have this
particular one i'm willing to train on
that and sometimes the recruiter doesn't
know that information um and it might
honestly change depending on how long
the role is open for and so
like i think what's best for the
candidate in that case is to try to get
as close to whoever the actual hiring
manager is as possible
and then just let them like give them
your resume and let them know your
experience because sometimes they'll
look at your resume and they would
absolutely love to give you an interview
where the recruiter might say
oh you don't meet x percent of the job
description therefore i'm not going to
pass it on
um so it's just it's one of those
disconnects between
having a third party sort of do that
interfacing
yeah i totally agree with that we don't
always do a good job um
specifying what like the key
skills that we want in a candidate and
you know some requests will just
um
say no reject people that are really
good
awesome thank you i know that hour just
went by very quickly somebody just asked
how do i stay informed about these calls
there's the data science hangout site
that libby just shared which has all of
the recordings and upcoming sessions if
you want to just add it to your calendar
directly you can use the link i just
shared there as well and that will just
add all of the recurring events
one other link i will share with you
this is actually a new quarto dock that
i just
made so i'm really proud of it right now
but um it's just the upcoming community
events so you can see both the meetups
and the hangouts there as
well um
yvonne do you have to run to another
meeting right
right now i don't want to keep you over
another minute
no no no no okay okay can i ask you one
more question
sure okay there was an anonymous
question that was
do you do any independent continuing
education to stay current um with new
technologies or does your company
provide training
so vote yes so yeah we have some some
funding to
to do our professional development
and i think that
the challenge here is the time
so when to do it and one of the things
that that has helped me a lot is to
participate in events like this one uh i
just hear new things and that helps me
and
and i can hear tools that are being used
and then i can't
spend some time to to see more of the
details of that um
so yeah i i really recommend you to do
like for example
keep going to these um hang outs go to
meetups or or to other conference that
will give you a lot of insight of what's
going on
and i try to do that a little bit
sometimes times doesn't allow to do to
do it um
but yeah for more formal training i will
use those
professional development funds that the
company uh gives me yeah
and i actually i need to force me to to
educate because otherwise i won't do it
so sometimes uh what i do is i commit
to get a certification or i tell other
people like hey let's do a study group
because otherwise i won't i won't do it
i know that i will quit so that's that's
something that i do to keep me on track
yeah
that's really helpful
thank you so much for sharing your
experience with us it was great to be
able to dive deeper into the data
engineering side as well oh thank you
this was great it was really fun so
thank you
if people want to stay in touch with you
what's the best way is linkedin or
twitter preferred
i like it uh no i think
uh what i use the most is leading but i
can put my
my glue in here
so yeah awesome i think that's the best
way to stay in dodgers i just connect
and yeah let's keep the conversation
thank you
perfect thank you all have a great rest
of day
you